do you think there's power to just
one-on-one conversation or Biden system
Biden sits down with Putin almost in
person
because I or maybe I'm romanticizing the
notion but having done these podcasts in
person I think there's something
fundamentally different than
through a remote call and also like a
distant kind of uh recorded political
type speak versus like man-to-man so I'm
deeply afraid that Putin outplays people
in the one-on-one scenarios because he's
done it to multiple presidents already
he gets in one-on-one scenarios with
bush with Obama with Trump with with
Biden and he seems to be a very canny
operator and a very sort of hard-nosed
operator in those situations I think
that if you were going to do something
like that like an actual political
face-to-face Summit what you'd need is
for Biden to First have a conversation
with zelenski where zelenski knows
what's going on so he's aware and then
Biden walks in and he says to Putin on
camera here's the offer
let's get it together let's make peace
you get to you get to keep this stuff
and then let Putin respond have Putin is
going to respond
um but you know the the big problem for
Putin I think and the problem with
public facing fora maybe it's a private
meeting if it's a private meeting maybe
that's the best thing there's a
public-facing forum I think it's a
problem because Putin's afraid of being
humiliated at this point um if it's if
it's a private meeting then
sure except that again I just I wonder
whether
when it comes to and a person as canny
as Putin and to
a politician that I really don't think
is a particularly sophisticated player
in in Joe Biden and again this is not
unique to Biden I think that most of our
presidents for the for the last 30 40
years have not been particularly
sophisticated players uh I think that
that's that's a that's a risky scenario
yeah I still believe in the power of
that because otherwise
um
I don't know I don't I don't think stuff
on paper and political speak will solve
these kinds of problems because From
zelenski's perspective nothing but
complete Victory will do right he is as
a nation has people sacrificed way too
much and they're all in and if you look
at as I travel to Ukraine I spent time
there I'll be going back there hopefully
also going back to Russia just speaking
to ukrainians
they're all in
they're all in
nothing but complete Victory yep that's
right and so for that the only way to
achieve peace is through like honest
human to human conversation uh giving
both people a way to off-ramp to walk
away Victorious and some of that
requires
speaking honestly as a human being but
also for America to the actually not
even America honestly just the president
be able to eat their own ego a bit and
be the punching bag a little just enough
for both presidents to be able to walk
away and say listen we got the American
president to come to us and uh I think
that makes the president look strong not
weak I mean I agree with you I think it
would also require some people on the
right people like me if it's Joe Biden
to say if Biden does that I see what
he's doing and it's the right move I
think one of the things that he's afraid
of to to Steel Man him I think one thing
he's afraid of is he goes and he makes
that sort of deal and the right says you
just cowered in front of Russia you just
you just gave away Ukraine whatever it
is
um but uh you know it's going to require
some people on the right to say that
that that move is the right move and
then he'll buy it if Biden actually
performs that move